[Music]
on the season finale of travel chairs
I'm picking Caroline to learn how to
play the Swiss outboard and I'm taking
Caroline to learn how to make Swiss
cowbells come join us on our adventures
on this episode of travel dares this is
travel dares the show where we do daring
activities all over Europe empowered by
my Mary a tomboy boundless card we've
been to seven amazing cities so far and
we're ending our journey in Lucerne
Switzerland - thank you for taking us
all over Europe me and Nico are taking
you on two special days we're gonna
start off with my dear first the better
there here's your loo here that's a
better day we all know that these clues
mean nothing my first instinct is to
think of like a boat i text booklet no
it has something to do with music music
no
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
okay guys there are three things that we
got to do first we got to figure out how
to play this thing second we're gonna
figure out how to hold these notes and
third is that we're gonna figure out how
we can play all together like a little
Swiss outboard band think you guys can
handle all I'm talking as if I played
this thing Mike hi guys my name is
anneka and I'm the translator oh really
he plays the ALP on professional and
he's gonna show you guys how to play the
alphorn
[Music]
there's so many
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
okay so we know how to play them now now
we just have to figure out how to hold a
tone okay so here's a little challenge
let's try to do low medium high note
AJ you start
[Music]
[Music]
it's time for our big band performance
yeah it's the moment of truth let's see
if we retained any knowledge okay all
right let's break it down
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you thank you she thank you go I'm
like really peaceful right now Sam just
leave me here
did you guys hear that I know you had a
good time are you ready to have an even
better time this dare might ring up
though okay I'm like redoing a dare or
something yeah dares I feel like we're
gonna be doing a dare that we've already
done but like amp it up like right here
[Music]
nice to meet you Olivia
so nice to meet you what is the first
step so first they have to fill this
form with sins so this oh this is heavy
and right here well that feels good some
nice nice chunk of cold add more sand
well who would have known that these
Bell making skills aging you for sure so
they have old letters so if you as a
customer you have a wish they can write
everything you want into the Bell what
[Music]
[Music]
but dick I don't even know what I'm
looking for but it looks right
what they're about to make my bow my god
at this place they were making the very
special valuable car bells in
Switzerland we make like presents for
weddings or birthdays or special events
and here you can see how this family
creates the bells it's a family
tradition
and you can make your own cow well so
with customized design with letters
[Music]
oh I know my Bell what I see her there
she is she's beautiful next step Paula
sensation I'm just gonna brush the bell
a little oh my god
this is like real gold it's looking
really good really well now it's the
moment of truth
oh how does it sound okay I got my I got
my felt don't I'm gonna fit into it look
it's gonna make it so heavy I actually
had so much fun on this dare thank you
you guys enjoyed it but I do have one
more surprise a double dare another day
you planned a surprise
Caroline and Nico will never guess a
surprise I have planned for them little
slower Nico over there Lud's behind you
okay perfect
now take off your blindfolds because
we're meeting Swiss cowbells are very
important because usually the cows are
by themselves in the mountains and so
you can hear them you can hear where
your herd is and you don't have to go
and find them because you know where
they are
I've never touched a cow before you're
so cute
[Music]
you guys so filling that's been so
amazing it's so beautiful people are so
nice it's listen it's just like a cute
small quick little town hotel and look
at the spread it looks so good
moment of truth my final rating and I
get to this time Nikko yes I didn't know
what to expect when you went up there
with us so this out born it is not an
easy thing to play to pick up to learn
but you were so passionate and
determined to learn all those tones so I
think I have to give you a 5 so you even
impressed Willie and AJ all right so
Caroline for the cowbell Vicki you were
so excited to do it
you're super involved at every step of
the process and I'm really proud of the
way that your Belle came out so for that
you getting another so many amazing
things but just so many beautiful places
but I gotta know do you have a favorite
dare oh I do do ya the water slide oh my
gosh that was amazing no I definitely
think my favorite was the soap making in
Marseille I wasn't expecting the process
to be as hard as it was but everything
smelled so good and it was so fun to cut
it all up it was awesome I have to say
my favorite it's absolutely the Swiss
out for it amazing I had such an
incredible time it was gonna be the
water bikes in Naples but the horn took
it away yeah she's gonna move here to
become a swiss out born Blair for sure
on top of that man guys what a way to
end our trip I'm really gonna miss you
we're gonna miss you
hopefully we can do it again soon yes
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]